I think it's becoming much clearer that
Parliament will try very hard to ruled
out no deal and that's why for people
who want to deliver what the British
people voted for in that referendum next
Tuesday's a very important moment
because we can no longer assume that by
rejecting this deal there will be a
better shade of brexit and what is more
likely if this deal is rejected is that
we have the risk of brexit paralysis and
when that happens no one knows what
might happen and the big risk and what
people worry about is that we don't
actually deliver what people voted for
well I think we shouldn't forget that in
the kind of unprecedented situation that
we're in things are changing very very
fast and the calculations that MP's are
making are changing and we've had the
news today that you know long-standing
brexit ears like Sir Edward Lee are
going to support the deal also truly
Harrison George Freeman and so MPs are
all reflecting and what they're all
thinking is what is the best way that we
can be true to our manifesto and true to
our constituents and make sure that we
really do deliver for our voters the
brexit deal that we promised